so there you go um
lots of questions uh about uh the
allegations in parliament today it did
field in it the two uh interviews there
and no specific ideas for what should
change
going forward
well let's move on to some other
subjects now uh shall we vladimir
putin's war on ukraine is grinding on
relentlessly his forces continue to take
land in the donbass despite the brave
resistance there in response nato
leaders have approved a huge increase in
high readiness forces they're also going
to be deploying more troops to eastern
europe and that's led to a debate here
over whether it's time for us to spend
more on our defence and what we should
spend it on
well i'm pleased to say we're now joined
by the former chief of the defence staff
lord richard dannet thank you very much
for being with us this morning
sophie good morning i'm delighted to be
here
great well we're delighted to have you
um it felt like the beginning of the war
uh was really dominated by stories of
ukrainian success and russia failing to
meet their aims whether it was taking
keeve or
so on
but now is it right that that feels like
it's turning and that actually russia is
making steady grueling progress but
still progress in the east is russia now
winning the war
um
no i wouldn't say russia is winning the
war it all depends what
russia's objectives are considered to be
your analysis is absolutely right at the
start the ukrainians did extremely well
the russians were woefully inept as far
as their military is concerned and they
realized that their desired lightning
strike from belarus to kiev just was not
going to happen that was a shambles and
that episode that chapter finished and
then they started what we've been seeing
working out over the last few weeks and
months this relentless grind in the
donbass to take donetsk province and
luhans province and to join up with the
land corridor that the russians have
achieved already from crimea through
mario paul to to donbass but um the
russian tactics the russian way of doing
business has completely changed since
that early failed attack they're relying
on their huge superiority
in artillery pounding the provinces of
donetsk and luhansk
and then once they've almost reduced
everything to rubble then sending their
troops in to
to take possession of it and we're going
to see that slow grind continue
they very nearly achieved taking luhan's
province and then they will turn their
sights to trying to get the control of
donetsk now i think probably what we've
seen over the last few weeks shows that
over the next few days and weeks they
will probably achieve that and at that
stage i believe the russians will be
exhausted they won't have won the war
that they'll have achieved some of what
they want to achieve getting those two
don best provinces the ukrainians will
also be exhausted um so the russians
won't have one the ukrainians won't have
lost and at that point i believe that
the war will effectively go in the into
the deep freeze and that's where
meaningful negotiations are going to
have to start
well that's in a way is where the big
questions begin too
if as you say it's almost inevitable
that russia ends up taking those two
provinces in the donbass
what then should the international
community do
should we accept that russia holds on to
the territory it takes in return for
peace
well
it's interesting you put the question
that way we
shouldn't do anything in terms of
deciding what should happen um this has
got to be the ukrainians deciding what
is going to happen the worst outcome for
the west for those of us who have been
supporting ukraine is for us to apply
pressure on the ukrainians to come up
with some kind of compromise some kind
of deal with russia and for the
ukrainians then to criticize would be
justifiably criticized the west was
saying well your soldiers short what we
absolutely have to do in the west is
continue to support ukraine
unequivocally continue pouring in
weapons and ammunition which we're doing
and it's up to president zielinski and
the ukrainians to decide what
negotiations they want to have
with the russians
and the fact the matter is if one looks
at it objectively is that once the
russians have captured as i said yes
they will the two provinces have donets
and liberates completely and we've got
that land corridor the world might tell
them to go but the russians will not go
and nobody can make them go the russians
won't go voluntarily the ukrainians will
not be strong enough to throw them out
and of course the west nato has got no
intention whatsoever of mounting a
kuwait type sort of expulsion operation
such as we did
to get rid of sarah hussein's forces
over from kuwait that's just not going
to happen so the new reality is that the
sovereign territory of ukraine probably
is going to be occupied to about 20
by russian troops and that's the
accommodation that the ukrainians have
got to get their head around they must
get their head around it we mustn't make
them put their head around it
that's really interesting because in a
way i've kind of wrongly thought of this
as a decision moment for ukraine or for
you know the international community
whatever i think you either decide to
russia is going to keep this uh land or
you're going to try and repel russia but
actually
perhaps the most likely scenario is
russia
maintaining control of the donbass at
the war and deep freeze but just going
on
tragically and sadly that could be the
case now of course i don't know how far
you want to extend this conversation but
if we believe that's going to be the
scenario in ukraine
it then for the rest of the west and
particularly other countries that border
russia there is then the lingering
threat of a resurgent and domineering
russia
which is why nato at its summit quite
recently has said that it wants to
increase from forty thousand to three
hundred thousand high readiness troops
not to fight the russians although
troops must be trained and prepared to
fight the russians but to deter the
russians from further aggression uh
elsewhere whether it's in the baltic
states or poland or wherever
and again again extending the
conversation a bit more it comes back to
our domestic considerations
under some pressure the prime minister
has now agreed to increase our defense
budget to move towards 2.5 percent of
gdp by the end of the decade but
here's another quite narrow point but
important point we're still going ahead
in this country with reducing our army
by 10 000 troops over the next few years
frankly that's madness because if
nato is going to go to 300 000 high
readiness troops we've got to play our
part in that and reducing our army
further just makes no sense whatsoever
so domestically we welcome the rise to
2.5
of gdp but we must reverse the cuts in
numbers to the army and also increase
our investment in our army our land war
fighting capability i'm afraid the
future is not going to be returned to
things
pre-24th february the future is going to
be a grumpy resurgent russia on the
borders of countries in eastern europe
we've got to play our part in deterring
further russian aggression that's
interesting that you say that that cut
to troop number numbers is madness and
how what impact would it have
on our defense capability i mean i guess
in simple language are we going to be
less safe as a result
well we are in land force terms we are
much less capable than we were 10 years
ago um 10 15 years ago we were fighting
two difficult campaigns with our army in
iraq and afghanistan and doing them
simultaneously with an army of over a
hundred thousand we're coming down to an
army of seventy odd thousand and we
could not maintain operations at the
scale that we were doing 10 15 years ago
um
people say you shouldn't focus on the
number you should focus on capability
well in the case of our maritime and air
forces that is correct because those
services are platform based you've got
to have smart ships you've got to have
smart aircraft but when it comes to
old-fashioned fighting numbers do matter
and to have an army of only just over
seventy thousand
thirty percent down from where we were
ten years ago is going to leave us
woefully short if we find that we've got
to maintain large number of troops at
high readiness forward deployed in
eastern europe um it's a mere fact of
life we'll we'll break the remainder of
our army if our army is not large enough
are trained well enough and to quit well
enough to do what the government of the
day wants us to do you you can't make
people work endlessly um with two
smaller numbers so numbers in the terms
of our land forces really really matter
uh it's fascinating to listen to you um
now this week the former uh national
security adviser kim darick said that
nato has to be ready for a russian
nuclear strike
do you agree and what does that mean
well the west is always ready to respond
to a nuclear strike um but let's not get
carried away with this
we absolutely do not want to see
anybody using nuclear weapons in europe
or elsewhere
we all know from our history books what
the awful consequence was of the two
atom bombs uh in japan in 1945 modern
nuclear weapons are much more powerful
than that we don't even want to see a
small tactical nuclear weapon are being
used so um kim derek is perfectly
reasonable to say what he has said but
we should be under no illusion that our
british nuclear deterrent is always at
high readiness so is the united states
ready to watch whatever russia might or
might not do
i think the thing that's really
important here is to
keep this conflict in ukraine within the
concept of what we would call a limited
war limited in geography
and limited by the means that are being
used and one of the limits is the tacit
agreement that neither side will use
nuclear weapons they might say they're
prepared to do so what's really
important is that our defenses are ready
and i think the other thing people have
got to remember perhaps be a little bit
less fearful is vladimir putin can't get
up one morning and think well this is
not going very well i'm going to push
the button even within the russian
nuclear firing chain it requires a
number of people to confirm that
decision and confirm certain actions so
he can't just get out of bed in the
morning and push a button it's not as
simple as that but um important thing is
that our defenses are ready but let's
keep this below the nuclear threshold uh
and work it out in
i was going to say a civilized way well
what the russians are doing is not
civilized but in a at least a vaguely
rational way
okay i understood uh very briefly as we
are out of time but there is one more
question i do want to squeeze in
we've seen of course um these very
upsetting stories about british people
being accused of being mercenaries by
russia two more british men are captured
by the russians and again accused of
being mercenaries is there anything that
the government
can do in this situation
well i think they can make
representations to
russia through through the ukrainians
reminding that these are british
citizens but
but you know um if people for their own
reasons decide to get themselves
involved in somebody else's war they've
really got to take the consequences of
of their own actions now that said the
death sentence being passed on to former
british servicemen who have been held um
that's really quite outrageous those
those two for example were properly
enlisted in the ukrainian army and
therefore they should be treated like
prisoners of war be they ukrainian or be
they british um this whole business is
most unfortunate but i would certainly
say to anybody that's thinking of
going adventuring a little bit into
ukraine be very very careful
this actually is not your fight but if
you find yourself
being taken prisoner by the russians
then frankly um it may be out of your
control it may be even out of the
british government's hands
thank you so much for being on the
program this morning it's been really
interesting i certainly feel like i've
learned something from the interview
thank you